[Music]
joe is with us joe is in boston mass hi
joe welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave i i just got married a couple
months ago congratulations
thank you very much um and
my wife and i
after taxes we make about uh 56 a year
and um
just did the math and uh you know get
trying to get on a budget and get out of
debt and our our expenses every month
come out to about
50 uh not not every month sorry every
year we have about uh fifty thousand
dollars a year so we only have a six
thousand dollar
savings and i know we're trying to get
out of debt too and um
really attack everything so i'm trying
to figure out how much extra
uh we need to make you know in a second
or third job uh you know for for the
both of us um as we move forward you
know trying to figure out how much
we need to
you know pay off debt and build up the
emergency fund how much debt do you have
uh it's about thirty thousand what's it
on
uh a car payment and student loans
how much do you owe on the car
about 24.
okay
sell it
we just we just bought it uh shouldn't
we say
you make fifty six thousand dollars a
year you put twenty five five thousand
dollars into a car that's going down in
value that you can't afford to pay the
payments on
we make
80s but you know take take-home pay is
56
and contain about 400 a month from the
car yeah
you shouldn't bought that car that's a
mistake
yeah it's the reason your budget's tight
wasn't tight for you did that
yeah it's 5 000 a year
yeah
and it's going down in value
yeah
this wasn't the conversation you wanted
to have is it
i i i had a feeling it would go this way
i knew it was stupid when i bought it
i'm sorry
picking on the newlyweds picking on the
newlyweds well you can do what you want
man uh but the the the
you know you could pick up an extra job
and and here's the thing as long as you
have vehicles
that equal half your annual income or
greater you're going to struggle with
finance
and you guys do because you put her car
with your car you're over half your
annual income
and uh or really really close
and
this was an impulsive
i owe myself kind of purchase
and um it was it was a mistake so
you can fight your way through it if you
want to fight your way through it i
don't think it's worth it to fight your
way through i think it's a stupid car
get rid of it but um but that really
shocked your system when i said it out
loud so
if you want to fight through it fight
through it but here's the thing get on a
written budget
and then work like six extra jobs and
you know how much do i need to make it
uh my extra job twenty four thousand
dollars if you're gonna keep a stupid
car
uh because it's got your it's got your
finances constipated that's what it
amounts to you're all blocked up
and that's why you're calling me you
can't breathe
and so
that that's what you're looking at now
you know
uh
i i
you know
again if you want to fight through it
you can it's the slow and the hard way
to do it
um and if i went through i i think you
so try it for a few months and you may
look up in the fall and go wow this is
really a bad thing i'm not liking this i
think dave was right he kind of scared
the crap out of me and i'm not sure i
like talking to him i don't even like
him that much but
maybe he was right
so
because our goal here is to make sure
that we give you the information joe
that's going to do the best for you
because we love you and we want you to
win
thank you for calling